ladies and gentlemen I wish you welcome
to the economics lecture which is held
by this year's laureate in economics
professor Angus Deaton and you see you
will see him alive in a moment you see
his cartoon there where he looks at the
earth in a microscope and it's sort of
meant to convey the image that he has
been studying consumption in different
perspectives the large very large
picture of macroeconomic consumption and
the very small picture of individual
consumers decisions individual
households decisions to consume you will
hear more about it during the lecture
I'm sure let's look at the official
motivation for the price which reads for
his analysis of consumption poverty and
Welfare and a few biographical details
he was he grew up in Edinburgh in
Scotland studied and got his PhD in
Cambridge England and now he lives in
Princeton the United States and I think
I shouldn't say anything more so I just
wish you welcome professor Deaton please
enter the stage
thanks so much
thank you so much it's a true wonder to
be here and I'm enormous ly grateful for
this award and today I'm going to talk a
little bit about some of the work I did
that was cited in the award so I'm going
to talk about behavior a welfare and
poverty there are some themes that I
want to highlight from the beginning one
of them is perhaps the overriding thing
that gains that has guided a tremendous
amount of my work over the years which
is inquiring into policy that makes
people people better off that can
improve well-being if you think about
this in the context of global poverty
for example the problem here I think is
not that there's any lack of tools and
policies there are many many policies
out there for whom advocates believe
that they can make the world a better
place but the key thing here is using
measurement as honest scorekeeping to
find out whether something is actually
working or whether it's not working at
all and one of the themes I'll emphasize
throughout is the enormous importance of
measurement almost by itself we're
always told there's no measurement
without theory and while that's true
it's more true just to say that
measurement is incredibly important and
it's often forgotten in economics just
how important measurement is the other
theme I'm going to talk about throughout
is individuals versus aggregates or
averages in a world in which you work
entirely on averages if you look at the
macro economy things like inequality and
poverty are simply not legible without
disaggregation without the details of
individuals the other thing is even if
you're only interested in the aggregate
economy
distribution clearly matters for
aggregate economic activity and
certainly for any serious analysis of
well-being finally we know that behavior
and well-being are linked for
individuals they're not linked for
aggregates so what you see from the
macroeconomy doesn't necessarily tell
you by itself whether people are doing
better or doing worse there's a theme
which runs through a lot of my work in
which is being challenged and I'm
sympathetic to that challenge which is
that if people by and large behave in
their own interests than by looking at
their behavior we can infer quite a lot
about how they are doing
it's what economists called revealed
preference analysis and it's always been
long been this standard in economics I'm
going to start at the very oldest stuff
and come up to stuff I've been doing
relatively recently and then move back
more chronologically so starting with
household surveys surveys which inquired
into people's living standards started
in the 18th century late in the 18th
century and have always been used then
and now as measurement for social
monitoring and for activism the idea
being to find out how ordinary people
live and by documenting how ordinary the
people live to bring that to the
attention of the ruling classes often to
shock them with the terrible living
standards of the poor and to shock those
people into trying doing something so
measurement as part of activism has been
very important dollar-a-day poverty
measures do the same thing today as do
data on infant mortality and stunting
and wasting in children children this
sort of simple documentation is not just
for poor countries I mean in rich
countries today we all know about
stagnant or falling real median wages
over time in the United States and in
some other countries the incredible
rises in income inequality that have
been taking place throughout many rich
countries and occasional rising
mortality rates but using mortality
rates is some sort of key for what's
happening to the population another
application that runs particularly in
poor countries is in agriculture
households just documenting whether
these people are not pursue MERS or net
producers of staple foods like rice or
wheat you can tell you a lot to the
first order about whether they're harmed
or herded by agricultural policy or by
tariff changes and these are again
examples of measurements that are just
unbelievably important in their own
right and take you a long way towards
thinking about policy one of the most
famous things of course is the analysis
of household budgets going back to Ernst
Engel in the nineteenth century who
looked at the food share and noticed
that richer households spend a smaller
share of their budget on food and poorer
households and there's been a long
subsequent literature trying to use that
as an indicator of welfare another theme
in that literature is looking at how
children alter the consumption patterns
of households and underlying that has
been a theme of trying to measure the
costs of children whatever that means
that's been a very difficult area
another issue that I worked on is
whether budgets are different if the
kids or girls or if the kids are boys if
you hold everything else constant and in
my work in in several other replications
people have actually find it
surprisingly hard to find evidence of
discrimination that way even when you
see the discrimination in society as a
whole another issue which i think is of
lasting importance and has been much
highlighted recently is why in spite of
rapid economic growth in India is per
capita calorie consumption falling in
spite of the mass malnourishment
especially among kids that exists in
India you would expect in a rapidly
growing economy with much malnourishment
the calorie consumption will be rising
rapidly in fact it's falling
we don't again really know why that
happens how do budget patterns change as
the household becomes larger and again
there's some major puzzles there on this
I wanted to highlight India many of
these questions I've great importance
for India much of the work has been done
on Indian data
and India was really the home of
probability sampling when Mahalanobis
started crop surveys in the 1930s and
1940s and funded the National Sample
Survey organization which has played a
large role in this analysis including in
my work one of the things you'd like to
know with surveys is you want to know
how people respond to prices and I'm
going to talk about that quite a bit
normally you can't do that from site
surveys but some surveys collect data on
quantities as well as expenditures so
you know for a household that they
bought three kilos of rice and paid so
much for it over the last week so you
can get some idea of how much they paid
for each kilo and you can use that to
analyze responses to prices across
different space one of the interesting
things about that work is it tends to
show these spatial price responses tend
to be quite large suggesting that
long-run responses which is what you're
perhaps picking up across space are
larger than short-run responses this is
important because it suggests that the
short run policy response the short run
price response that we usually model may
greatly underestimate the distortions
which policy might cause em in the long
run I wanted to highlight to some open
issues here one is in these household
survey data the quality of the data are
often not up to the task which is put to
them this is particularly true in Africa
but not always in Africa there's also
wide spread throughout the world and
perhaps its worst in India a conflict
between the data that comes from the
national accounts and the data that come
from the household surveys and so in
India the growth that everyone is so
very proud of in GDP per capita really
does not show up to anything like the
same extent in the household surveys
this really means that you cannot have a
coherent discussion about well-being
inequality and poverty in India because
the two sources of data for which you'd
be able to connect up growth with
poverty and inequality are mutually
inconsistent and you really can't see
anything sensible and then what happens
is each political side picks its own
database
and they go to a completely fruitless
war talking against each other and the
data never get improved India's perhaps
the worst case here but these problems
exist really widely throughout the world
I wanted to say a few words about
international comparisons because if
you're gonna compute global poverty or
look at the state of the world's poor
you've got to have some method of
comparable making comparable
measurements across different countries
with different currencies and different
consumption patterns one of the greatest
intellectual achievements in measurement
over the last 50 years is the
International comparison program which
was begun at Penn by Kravis summers in
Hesston Allan Houston is sitting in the
front row here in 1968
it's an enormous achievement which sadly
has never been recognized here in the
way that it should have been the ICP is
still very active both in measurement
and conceptual advances and indeed there
remain very large challenges and it's I
also find it a little sad that
relatively few economists work on this
in spite of the enormous intellectual
challenges that there are there to do it
so let me move on to some of the earlier
work I did on analyzing consumption
patterns in the 1960s and 70s demand
analysis as it's called the study of
consumption patterns was concerned with
using aggregate data to fit the
quantities consumed to prices to data on
prices and income
I came to Cambridge to the Cambridge
growth model as a research assistant in
the late 1960s and I was asked to look
after the demand system estimation and
to think about consumption and saving in
the growth model this was a project
headed by Richard stone who was the
Nobel laureate in 1984 that was the
impetus for much that I did subsequently
or indeed if you were being unkind you
should think that I was given this task
as an RA and I'm still working on it
almost 50 years later having never found
anything better to do
or at least I find lots of fascinating
things to do there when when I showed up
in 1969 stones linear expenditure system
was used as part of the growth model
it's a very simple case of additive
preferences which without going into
that in detail what it does is it gives
you a very tight link between the way
the man's respond to income and the way
that demands respond to prices now think
of 1969 1970 we were working with about
18 annual observations instead of the
millions millions of observations we
have today so having a very restricted
tight specification like this was
extremely useful in fact is probably all
you could have done in those days but
and I remember this troubling me from
the very beginning when I worked on this
that we were basically assuming answers
that we ought to be measuring them and I
always find that extremely troubling so
we needed more general but still
tractable models I was also worried from
the very beginning about the nature of
the representative agent assumption that
was built into these models that we were
pretending there was one single person
who was behaving for the whole aggregate
economy so how did that come about well
it turned out that a lot of the results
were actually known at that time and
turns Gorman who played a very important
part in my life had proved the results
on aggregation of our goods and
aggregation over people it proved these
results in papers in the 1950s and 1960s
the trouble is these papers use the dual
representation of preferences in which
you think of well being is defined by
prices and incomes rather than by
quantities and if you'd grown up
studying conventional economics those
papers were incredibly hard to read at
that time they don't seem so hard now
and I remember going off to try to read
those papers and locking myself in a
room for a week and I was determined
that I would not come out of the room
until I'd really understood what that
paper was about and I came out at the
end of the week and I knew absolutely no
more that I did
at the beginning of the week but slowly
there began to be a little bit of
understanding dan McFadden at the same
time had realized these results were
known to theorists but there were
relatively few people of which Gorman
and McFadden were the most notable who
had understood that this dual
representation was really the way to
derive theoretically consistent demands
that were analytically convenient for
actually adapting and studying the data
so that was the the major breakthrough
that those two guys understood and not
too many other people at the time dead
now Johnny Ober is sitting here too and
I'm gonna talk a little bit about him
John
came back to the UK from doing a PhD in
Berkeley in 1969 he had been advised by
Bob Hall I recently asked Bob Hall you
know where did your lecture notes come
from he said I just stole them from Dan
McFadden so you know Dan McFadden was
sort of behind a lot of this at the time
and Dan had these wonderful lecture
notes on consumer and producer theory
using duality which I remember became a
sort of Bible again you people today
cannot imagine how the world was before
the web and when people had written
these incredibly important papers but
never published them and getting a hold
of them was unbelievably difficult you
almost had to send rescue squads and to
find these papers and steal them and
bring them but when John came back from
Berkeley we met each other and we
realized that we knew a lot of the same
material that was otherwise not so very
well known and we decided that it was a
really good thing to pull what we knew
and explain our newfound knowledge to
the world as a whole a very arrogant
thing for two kids and their 20 year
olds to do but that eventually turned
into our joint text on economics and
consumer behavior now at the same time
we wanted to get away from the problems
with a model like the linear expenditure
system and built a better tool for
analyzing demand and so we spent I think
probably a year and a half or so
tinkering and fiddling trying to find a
real
good a perfect demand system much of
this was based on Jamil bars earlier
work on irrigation on a functional form
another important thread on this was our
Wendy works work on flexible functional
forms which broke this very tight
restriction and allowed you to fit
something that was about as general as
could possibly be hanging you handled so
we tinkered with these dual
representations to get a convenient easy
to estimate demand system we almost got
everything we wanted and that was why it
was called the almost ideal demand
system and it still remains very widely
used today it's certainly not a perfect
model but one of the things they did
that had not been done in these demands
before was it got away from the
representative agent at least to the
point where an equality played a role in
the pattern of the demand in a serious
way and that was really the contribution
of John's work on irrigation came to its
fruition in this joint work that we did
together so let me move on from the
consumer demand to intertemporal choice
which was the third area that the
committee had identified and talk about
saving first there were two papers
famous papers written by Franco
Modigliani and Richard Brahm Romberg do
is I think a graduate student at the
time
there were written in the 1950s only one
of which was published in an edited
volume and the other one was available
then I remember reading it even when I
was an undergraduate in Cambridge in the
library Bromberg died very very young
and I think Franco Modigliani never
really had the heart to publish that
paper so once again it remained a sort
of secret document when I read those two
papers to me it was a revelation of how
I wanted to do economics and really
shaped a lot of what I've tried to do
ever since these models have this very
clear very simple theoretical structure
in which the life cycle is modeled they
give you a way of thinking of
an issue of enormous importance for
understanding the well-being of people
and for understanding public policy
almost anything to do with savings and
pensions for instance you have to think
about it in some form like this the
other thing that impressed me enormously
about those papers was when they were
written a lot of people had worked on
savings in consumption and there was a
mass of results mutually contradictory
results from cross-section time series
across countries all sorts of stuff and
no one understood how it hung together
or any coherent sense and those papers
systematically said here is the story
which can actually reconcile a huge
amount of this evidence so it give you a
lens in which suddenly everything came
into focus
and you could figure out what was
actually going on the other thing that
appealed to me down and appeals to me
now and I'd love to tell non economist
about this when they say what does
economics ever done that's not obvious
in the life cycle hypothesis each person
doesn't do any savings over the life
cycle the simplest version at least
because they humilate wealth when
they're young and they spend it when
they're old and so they're not savings
over their life cycle is nothing and you
might say well how can that explain an
economy in which there's not savings and
what Mattingly yani realized was that in
a growing economy the young people were
savings on a larger scale than the
elderly we're dis saving and therefore
when you aggregate it up to the economy
as a whole you got a completely
different result from the individual
behavior in which rate of growth effects
produced the savings rates I mean this
is really wonderful this is the opposite
of a representative agent and it's not
just thinking about aggregation as being
a nuisance to be gotten rid of it's
actually a positive force for coming out
and understanding the world and I this
to me was an enormous revelation and one
of the sadder things about my later wife
is life is the work that Chris Paxson I
did in which we pretty much convinced
ourselves to my great distress that the
story is not right and that you know the
evidence can be hard even to really very
beautiful pieces of theory there were
also a number of major innovation
in the 1970s and I've been trying in the
last few weeks to trace this back which
was a simultaneous theory of lifecycle
labor supply in commodity demands and
it's clear that Jim Heckman is princeton
PhD thesis in 1971 was a very important
part of this there was that important
work by Becker Gilbert gas by Hackman
and then later a very famous paper by
Tom mccurdy this is a world in which
it's realized that inter temporarily
additive preferences can give you demand
systems within each period of the form
that we'd always used except instead of
income
these were linked together by the
marginal utility of money which solved
which enforced the life cycle wealth
constraint the thing that was also
beautiful about that formulation was
that it allowed you to incorporate
uncertainty which is something that many
of us were still struggling with
empirically at that time and the
marginal utility wealth evolved this
martingale difference if this model is
sort of working in the right way when we
first started working on that I
developed a method of tracking birth
cohorts through successive independent
household surveys you would really like
to have panel data which is what mccurdy
had used but that's very hard to do and
I developed this tool that in some ways
was not just an inferior substitute but
gave a different way of using data that
were much much more widely available and
had certain advantages to track what was
happening over time I'll come back to
that in the paper with Martin browning
and Margaret Irish we were somewhat
skeptical that the model actually
explained anything very much and wages
for instance our hump shaped over the
life cycle they rise in middle-age
according to the simple version of the
theory consumption should be much
flatter but it isn't it's from shape too
we also find that the business cycle and
life cycle frequencies of consumption
and savings really could not be easily
reconciled now there's been enormous
later work following this up using the
same sort of cohort methods and that
later work has been much more positive
than we were though I'm not totally
convinced if only because it's come at
great cost in terms of simplicity it may
of course also be true as we first
thought that these simple lifecycle
models are not true and that people may
not be able to easily borrow and spend
as is assumed in those models so that
after doing that I moved on to thinking
about what became known as buffer stock
savings this is a world in which people
can't borrow to fund their consumption
and so they can only accumulate their
own assets and spend it this again
seemed particularly relevant in
developing countries where there were
very poor credit markets and possibly
very high interest rates now Gila rock
was also here and I had started working
around the same time on the
mathematically identical model of
commodity prices which have been
developed by Gustafson at the University
of Chicago in their 30s and with a lot
of help from gate I worked on this
within the consumption context and this
is one of the very few pieces of work in
my life where I've taken what is
nowadays called the dynamic structural
approach to the data and I learned an
enormous amount from that which is why
I've always been fairly sympathetic to
this approach one of the things that
these models produce is that people do
not lift hand to Mai's they don't simply
spend their income in every period and
although they rarely hit the borrowing
constraint they behave very differently
because of the presence of the budget
constraint constraint so this is a sort
of magic feature of this model that you
put this potential threat in there and
it completely changes people's behavior
even though the threat is never actually
materialized and so that was something I
learned from doing this work that I had
no idea at all and people do say that
this safe to smooth and protect
themselves against the lean years in the
fluctuations in their incomes and
subsequently that model and related
models have become one of the basic
workhorses for thinking about savings
and consumption another great innovation
in the 1970s at the same time had been
Bob Paul's work
and I say I remember in Johnny Oh bar
bringing me that paper when we were in
Bristol together and saying you've got
to read this paper and Bob had reworked
Friedman's permanent income theory using
rational expectations ideas which were
very new and current at the time and
this this is what is sometimes called
the random walk theory of consumption
then it opened up an enormous subsequent
torrent of research one of the things
that was very useful to me was that
within that framework in very simple
cases it was possible to derive explicit
formulas which told you what the change
in consumption should be when there were
innovations in the stochastic process
driving earnings so if you could model
the stochastic process driving earnings
you look very precise statements about
what should be happening to the
consumption a wonderful thing for an
empiricist to have and to look at but I
was very puzzled when I was doing this
because I thought I'd gone crazy and I
was getting wildly inconsistent
contradictory results and what turned
out there was that if you took what at
that time was the most popular and
plausible stochastic process for
earnings it actually implied that the
permanent come hypothesis had two
opposite implications for why the
permanent income hypothesis had been
invented which was that it predicted
that consumption should not be smoother
than income which it is in the data but
the consumption should be less smooth
than data so it was this here was this
basic theory taught in every textbook
and it actually had the opposite
productions to what people and thought
people got very angry with me for
writing that paper and I remember being
shouted at in seminars and told that if
I couldn't do anything better than that
I should go and be a fly fisherman or
something more useful though one counter
example to that was I got a letter which
I really prized at the time from Bob
Solow which started off saying this is a
fan letter and then just told me how
wonderful he thought that paper was so
if someone was on my side of course
there are lots of ways of resolving this
paradox and one of which once again is
to work with individual data and not
work at the aggregate
because one of the things there are many
parts of this resolution but one of the
things that is true is that the
stochastic process for individuals when
you aggregate them up to the economy as
a whole completely change their
stochastic properties so in some sense
this whole thing was a false dichotomy
but it reinforced once again that we
should be working at the micro level and
not working and aggregates so the final
thing I want to talk about is the
consumption inequality and this is work
I did with Chris Paxson and the random
walk theory consumption has another
startling implication which is if you
take a bunch of people and you put them
outside the door here of the aula magna
you take a hundred people and you
instruct them to walk off randomly in
all directions and you go away for a day
or two and then you come back they will
be scattered all over Stockholm even
though they started in exactly the same
place and so this even each one of them
is has an increment to their behavior at
any given time that's a stationary
stochastic process you're generating
this non stationary behavior it's sort
of like a people sitting around the
roulette wheel and they start with all
the same stacks but in the end they
finish up some people with big stacks
and some people with small stacks so
this this risk even stationary risk can
be accumulated at the consumption
inequality that wealth inequality
increases even more rapidly than
consumption inequality unless of course
there's some offset for instance from
insurance arrangements in society that
tied together people's earnings or tie
together the consumption independently
of their earnings and so you can use the
spread of consumption over time to
assess the degree to which society is
actually ensuring its members a sort of
very important idea in economics as to
what extent societies do ensure their
members against the ravages of luck
Chris Paxson and I find that in several
countries we looked at the data behaved
in the way that we predicted which of
course is subject to what I think of as
poppers curse you know coppers that
popper says that it
reject the hypothesis you learned
something of course you're much more
pleased if you'd confirm your hypothesis
if no one's looked at that before but
poppers curse is that someone else will
think up of another explanation for that
and it doesn't prove your Theory's right
at all
nevertheless these ideas the spreading
in equality and the matching of these
higher moments of consumption to the
data have become a sort of central idea
in what is called heterogeneous agent
macroeconomics today and the modeling of
the stochastic process of earnings is a
very central area to now and the brief I
was given I was told to talk about my
discoveries I think they probably send
this text to everybody and it's not
entirely clear whether economists are
supposed to have discoveries and I think
of discoveries as sort of apples falling
on your head
but those apples only set off good ideas
if someone has prepared your head before
and so it's a very collaborative
activity so I wrote down some of the
things I'm most proud of and one is
something I haven't talked about which
is early in my career when Ted Heath was
Prime Minister of Britain and the
government lost control of inflation and
I was young father and I would go to the
store and I thought all individual
relative prices were going up because
the result is unanticipated inflation so
I predicted that this unanticipated
inflation would actually increase
savings without people wanting to
increase savings and I thought that was
a ridiculous prediction and so did
everyone in the common room at Cambridge
and I was widely laughed at until it
became true and the data of course then
poppers curse trucks again strike again
and there are lots of other stories for
why that might be happening but for me
that was the first time in my life that
I came up with a prediction that seemed
ridiculous and turned out to be borne
out in the data I talked a little bit
already about the creating panel data
from a time series of cross-section
which is more a tool than a discovery
but it's helped investigate a wide range
of substantive questions and it's now a
standard technique more by macro than
micro people I talked about my
realization that popular
kinds of the permanent income hypothesis
were self conduct contradictory and
that's again been very productive and I
realized and I think this is probably
the thing that I must pry it off to this
days the work that Chris Paxton I did
realizing that these various filtering
behaviors or responsive behaviors so
that you can have a driving stochastic
process in which there's completely
uncorrelated risk which nevertheless can
drive in rising inequality I mean
something that I think is very relevant
for what we're going to do today so I'm
almost out of time and I just wanted to
end by showing you some pictures of some
of the people I've collaborated with
over the years there's John Mille bar
sitting down there Gila rock Chris
Paxson will be here tomorrow Martin
browning this is John Campbell this is
my friend John drehs who I worked with
in India here's Alan Heston and Betina
anton who's sitting in the front row
here and most recently I've been working
on well-being with Danny Kahneman and
Arthur stone and trying to bridge this
sometimes unbridgeable gaps between
economists and psychologists and these
are people that I never wrote papers
with but whose work had a really
definitive effect on the shape of my own
work there's Richard stone who really
was my mentor who won the prize in 1984
you can see I've been imitating his
bowtie ever since though I don't think
I've ever dared risk this combination of
stripes the he had there never mind the
black onyx cigarette holder which was
sort of very much a part of the pattern
- there's turns Gorman up at the top
here this is the only photograph I could
find I even went to the econometric
society archives and very
characteristically Terence Gorman never
turned in his photograph as president of
the econometrics society so you can find
the president in the year before and the
president the year after but there's no
photograph in the 1973 archives
tall that's Franco Modigliani who find
out that I was working on lifecycle
hypotheses long before I knew enough to
talk to Franco and was completely
overwhelmed the same was true with
Terrence Gorman I mean he always assumed
you knew more than he did which was
terribly bewildering until you got a lot
further along there's Jim Heckman on the
top right there who is again not just in
life cycle work but in many other things
I've done in my life has been quite a
decisive influence that's a march his
son who I haven't really talked about
but it has he has been responsible for
what I think of as a lifetime commitment
thinking ethically about the
implications of my work and trying to
bring some sort of ethical dimension to
economics there's Dan McFadden who with
Terence was one of the early people who
brought do allottee to demand and
there's Bob Hall on the bottom right who
did this funded work on consumption
functions and changed everything around
1978 so thank with thanks to them and
thanks to you all for listening thank
you very much indeed
particularly interesting for us on the
committee who have studied this work but
didn't really know all these threads
back in history there was the one detail
that maybe you didn't know maybe you
left it out for the sake of brevity and
that which we discovered when we were
preparing the report on you and that was
that one of the fundamental papers by
john muir Bauer on aggregation was
actually first published as a working
paper in economics here at Stockholm
University in 1976 that's our claim to
fame in this prize so I suppose we give
a warm applause not only Trang's Deaton
but also to those people that he has
mentioned some of whom are actually here
with us today so thank you very much